Hello. Hello. Hello.
Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today,
we have another workshop
as part of the complete guide to Teleport
course.
Today, we'll be diving deep into a role
based access control.
Taking a look at what Teleport provides for
us to secure our infrastructure,
using a paradigm that we're hopefully all familiar
with from other systems such as Kubernetes.
All right.
Hello,
Abdul.
Welcome.
Hello, Jeffrey.
Thank you for joining.
So I'm gonna dive straight in.
If you've been following along with this course,
then you'll know that
all the README files are on GitHub.
You can find them at github.com/rockwoodacademy/courses.
This is part 10,
the RBAG deep dive, and we've got
six,
six
exercises.
I can't even remember. Six exercises to work
through today to kind of introduce us
and show us all of the cool things
that Teleport brings
along with its RPAC model.
So we're gonna start off nice and simple.
Now, the setup required, if you want to
follow along on your own time,
or even just do this at your own
time, is that you will need a uninitialized
Teleport cluster.
So
what do I mean by uninitialized?
Well, just that you have installed Teleport.
You can have started Teleport, but we haven't
really created that first user yet. And that's
where I'm gonna start from today.
So let's make this a little bit bigger,
go.
And our first exercise is really just to
get familiar
with the base roles that Teleport
provides
out of the box.
So by default,
Teleport provides
editor,
auditor,
and access roles.
The editor role allows editing of cluster configuration
and settings.
Auditor will allow you to read cluster events,
audit logs and playback session records.
And access gives you access to the resources
that are secured with Teleport,
which could be
nodes with the
agent on it, applications that are heading behind
the proxy,
Kubernetes clusters,
and as of recently with Teleport eight, Windows
desktop access.
So all those things that Teleport secures
can be available via the access role,
which makes sense slightly intimidating,
but we're gonna show you today
how to get more fine grained permissions with
this model.
Okay.
So Abdul,
waiting for this. This is the first time
it was scheduled.
Yeah. I have had to delete this
this session a few times
because
of sickness and because of bad weather in
Scotland, which makes getting to my office a
little bit more difficult.
It's just been a bit tricky, but I'm
really glad that we get to do it
today.
Mozz is asking, does Teleport apply a rule
on an active connection?
I'm gonna have to interpret what I think
you're asking there.
So if we if you log in and
you have a role that is assigned to
you,
any changes to that role will apply to
your active session.
If your role is if you have a
role added to your account while you're logged
in, you'll have to log out and back
in to have access to that role.
If you're logged in and a role is
removed from you, Teleport gets quite angry and
will actually encourage you to log back out.
So hopefully that answers your question.
Excuse me.
Jeffrey.
Oh, another Jeffrey. Hello, Jeffrey. Welcome.
And Mozz, I've just answered that one. Cool.
So these workshops are 100% interactive.
Please get your questions and I will do
my best to answer anything that I can.
And anything that I can't answer is material
for me to go and research and make
more awesome videos sharing this awesome tool.
Okay, so we've got three base roles available
to us by default. I have included
the roles at the bottom and I figured
we could
maybe just take a look at what is
available inside of this specification,
so we understand how it works.
So this is the editor role and you
can see they've pretty much got access to
all resources and every command available to it.
So this is their everything role that allows
you to
pretty much do whatever you want.
And you can see that we can modify
the OpenID Connect integration. We can actually modify
roles,
users,
and we can change the SAML configuration, the
GitHub authentication integration,
everything.
All
the way down.
But there's no ability here to access
any applications,
nodes, Kubernetes clusters, etcetera.
And there is no session replay or other
things.
So you don't get
everything, but you get a lot
at least on an administrative or operational point
of view.
Then we have the auditor role.
So we can see here that they have
the ability to list and read sessions.
They can also list and read the events.
Now it doesn't matter if you're not familiar
with how these exposed via the CLI or
the UI, we'll be taking a look at
all of us again
in a few short moments.
I'm not actually sure what this login is.
I think it's just there to provide an
empty list so the default isn't included. I
should really check, but we're just gonna ignore
that one for now anyway.
And then we have the access role, which
pretty much ships with a bunch of stars.
And we'll talk about what that means and
we'll even modify
a role very much like this in today's
session.
So the access gives us access to the
applications behind Teleport. Star star means all applications.
If we want to be able to access
databases,
we've got.
Now
this is where we see this handlebar
syntax, much less syntax depending on what community
and ecosystem you come from.
This is interpolation inside of Teleport and this
means that the value is going to be
handled
just in time based on the user that
is logged in.
When we see internal dot, this is a
trait as an exercise where I will explain
that in more detail later.
But it just means that although the database
labels says that you have access to all
databases,
the names of the databases that you can
access and the users that you can access
the databases
as,
is not a star, and that's important.
I'm not gonna cover impersonation
in today's workshop, mostly
because of time constraints, but more importantly is
that I haven't really found a use case
for Teleport's impersonation
that I like.
The examples from the website, and maybe we'll
take a look at them towards the end,
I'm talking about having an account and a
CICD process that can take on an elevated
permissions for a short time.
But I haven't been able to find a
way to integrate that into my own workflows.
And I don't really wanna be disingenuous
and show it off. But if you have
a use case that makes sense for you,
share it with me. I'd love to know.
But I I personally haven't found a real
world use case for impersonation that I want
to share with anyone.
Okay. We then have access to the Kubernetes
scripts, labels and users.
We've got logins.
So, you know, when you have access to
Starstar
nodes,
well, what logins can I use to access
those nodes? By default, it is
the ones provided when we create the account.
Node labels, and then there's a little bit
of rules just meaning
you can access notes, then you can listen
with the events,
which makes a lot of sense. We then
got the Windows desktop integration and then some
boring stuff at the bottom.
So you can see these manifests
look like Kubernetes manifests.
So they feel instantly familiar.
They're using the same concept of resource and
verb again, instantly familiar if you're coming from
a Kubernetes background.
So after a little bit of trial and
error and playing and customizing roles with your
own Teleport clusters, this becomes really easy to
work with.
So I hope you have some fun with
it.
Okay. So let's go back up to this
first exercise and we've entered just the roles.
What we wanna do is now just get
access
to the cluster that we have that is
uninitialized, and we're gonna just kinda cover this
command. Like we've typed this many times throughout
this course,
but never really digged into what it meant
to be an editor, an auditor, and have
access to Teleport resources.
And now we do.
Okay.
Let's see. We got a couple more hellos
and then I'll start typing some stuff in
a terminal. Evan Ash, welcome back.
And Russell, welcome back to you too. Hello.
I have been tweaking and playing with my
audio like mad. So I hope that I
sound all right. And if there are any
problems, please do let me know.
Alrighty.
Let's
see. So here is my Teleport cluster,
teleport.rockode.live,
there's no user created yet, I cannot log
in, we have to do that first.
So I'm gonna jump over to here and
log in to teleport.rawcode.live.
I feel like my font has gotten smaller.
It has, hasn't it? If I've been changing
my font size,
let's just quickly bump that back up.
There we go.
Russell.
He still sounds Scottish, is that intentional?
Aye,
it is.
Just be glad you're getting my English voice
on these dreams and not my Scottish voice.
Anyway,
okay.
Focus.
We wanna run
back to my course. We wanna run this
command.
So Teleport Control, TCTL,
users add, I'm going to add a user
for me, Rawkode.
We're going to assign the roles, editor, auditor,
and access.
I hit return, we get the link that
will allow us to pop this open and
register our account. I will say use this
password,
we'll call this Rawkode live stream.
My username is Rawkode
and we'll hit save and I'll just need
to copy
Rawkode livestream.
Where is it?
That password just appeared.
Oh, but it's showing up there. That's okay.
I'm gonna have to open this here. So
that I can
scan
my QR code and
paste this in.
Sweet. We now have access to our Teleport
cluster
and let's see.
Okay. So Jeffrey,
what about impersonate a Kubernetes grouper user to
see what kind of access and permissions that
user would have?
Yeah. That's interesting.
Hey, I guess you could have it configured
in a way
where,
yeah, you could elevate your privileges inside of
a Kubernetes cluster
to
run some integration tests or something like that.
There could be something there, I'm gonna think
about that a little bit more.
And Khalid, hey man, welcome back.
Okay, so we have access to our cluster,
there's nothing in this, this is uninitialized
Teleport, at least it was until we got
started creating our account, but you can see
that we've got the ability to view activity
and recession records and auto logs. This is
the auditor role.
The editor role is the one where I
can modify users roles and off connections also
available here. Custers not doing anything with,
but what we do want to do is
just
I actually expected the server to be here.
We will just enable that then. We
wanna take a look at
something I omitted intentionally
from our TCTL command here.
And if you've already spotted that, feel free
to say in the comments, but I am
going to quickly modify our Teleport YAML here.
We do have an SSH service on.
Peculier.
I don't wanna debug on this show. Come
on.
I already have that running.
Alright.
Quickly, what have I missed? What have I
missed? What have I missed?
This is I'm gonna restart Teleport.
I can always start another SSSSSSSSSS
proxy.
Okay. So I'm a bit confused normally.
In fact, every other time that I have
done this,
the server where our Teleport process is running
would show up
here.
And that is not the case.
Alright. Well, you know what? We can fix
this. Let's go to the Teleport documentation.
Or docs.
Oh, what's that? There we go.
And server access, getting started.
I can always add a static node
and start this proxy on my own.
That is exactly how I set up my
cluster.
Okay.
Let's just make it work.
Not important. I'm not offended. Teleport is all
good.
This is a node token.
Probably shouldn't show you that.
And we'll start another teleport thing.
Change that token path. I really should just
do the static one, shouldn't I?
I was trying to be
better than that.
ML server is
Teleport.Rawkode.live44three.
E S c h.
Classy.
Cool.
Connected.
Teleport.
Is this a permission this year already?
I haven't done anything exciting yet.
Oh, and now my building is having Pericos.
Am I still alive?
This is the start of a horror movie,
isn't it?
I think I'm still alive.
Well, Moza has given me hints for my
Teleport cluster problem, so hopefully I'm still alive.
Okay.
I'm
confused, but I'm gonna assume
I have done something wrong,
but we can fix that.
And I've done this all this Teleport cluster
today. I'm not sure if I'm on the
well, I will be on the definitely on
a % on the latest version. I don't
know if something has changed. So we're gonna
try and fix it all. So we're gonna
do
I'm gonna close this thing because I don't
think I need to be running this.
And I don't see servers, so I think
it's permission issue. Now let's go back to
the workshop for a second and we'll cover
what I should have covered.
So
if we look So we're created a user
and exercise two is to introduce us. Thank
you, Miles. Thank you for confirming the install
online even though power did appear to go
out for a few seconds.
So I wanna introduce you to traits and
Teleport. And what I'm saying here is that
before we talk about that, I want you
to Teleport
using to SSH enter the node using Teleport
and run Whoami.
And you actually can't do that yet because
we didn't specify
which logins our user had access to on
our tctl
users add command.
Typically, when we've done this before in the
course, we see logins root,
which means I will have the ability to
log in to all of the machines
as the root user.
So we can't actually do that and the
reason why is because of Teleport's traits. Now
when we went through the role YAML at
the start,
we kind of, I introduced it a little
bit and said that anytime you see interpolation
syntax, mustache slash handlebars
with internal dot, that this is going to
be a trait that is applied or
inherited from the user
and to the role just in time.
So, well, the access role allows connecting to
Teleport node, it does use a it does
use a trait.
So,
what I suggest we do here
is to pull down our user.
Now you can edit some stuff from the
UI, but I'm gonna try and use the
CI as much as possible and the YAML
format, because this is what at the end
of the day is gonna be
automatable by you and your systems.
And while we're doing this, we're gonna try
and debug why I don't have access to
the node.
So the first thing I'm going to do
is pull down
my user, my user is actually Rawkode here,
not my email address,
like so.
And this will get me the YAML for
my user.
So we can ignore the metadata, we can
see that I do have the rules that
I expected to have.
We've got some Kubernetes traits that we don't
need to worry about at the moment and
logins is null.
What I'm gonna do is get myself access
to,
to
the root
user,
and we can save this.
I can then use TCTL
create dash F Rawkode
to apply this back
to the cluster.
Now, if we come to the server
and go to team and users,
If I click on edit, you'll see we
only have the ability to change the rules.
We can't actually do the traits through the
UI. Although when it comes to rule stuff,
you can change most,
if not everything for the UI.
So let's see how this access thing works
with that trait that we have.
So we've got the access rule
where app is star star,
Kubernetes is not star star,
node labels is star star.
There is no reason I shouldn't be able
to SSH onto this node right now.
But logins here, you can see that it's
using that logins value trait from my user
account.
I could also modify this rule and just
say that anyone with access has root access
to the box,
and that would also work just fine.
Let's jump back in.
This looks good.
Oh, there we go.
And now
it's showing up.
So let's work out why,
because I'm not happy with that.
I'm gonna change this back to the trait
for the logins,
right?
So, because I've added that to my user
account
login,
like so, and that's save.
And it's not there. Cool.
So this makes a little bit of sense.
This must be something new that the Teleport
has changed.
And I'll explain that in just a second.
In fact, we can test my hypothesis,
which is gonna be even more fun.
So when I changed
the role,
because I am logged in
with the role access right now,
I immediately seen
the server
when I changed the role and to not
use the trait and to be hardcoded with
Root. However, when I modified my user, I
did not re log in again and that
trait is not part of the certificate
that identifies me.
And my hypothesis is that Teleport Agent is
now user aware
on the host and knows that I have
no users available on that machine to connect
to.
What used to happen was you could click
connect,
use the trait value of your username, and
then it would crash
or at least you'd get the terminal, but
it would say there is no user.
And I really wanna test this.
Although I'm
I'm now curious if I create a user,
the add user, user add Rawkode,
whether the agent will detect that or I'll
have to restart Teleport.
But I'm still more than happy to find
out.
Now if I want to get myself a
home directory, I can't remember how to do
that.
Dash d for defaults.
So,
nope. Alright. User add Rawkode is. Okay. Home
there.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
But let's let's test.
Okay. So it's not allowing me. Restart Teleport.
I thought it was good to take the
user and let me do it. Anyway,
let's log out,
get our trait value into our certificate,
and then we'll have access to that machine.
There we go. Cool.
That's
interesting.
Yeah.
Let's see. Normally that's with less my trait
value of Rawkode two, but it's not.
So I'm gonna work that out, but I'm
not gonna do it on this stream because
we've got too much to cover.
Okay. Let's see.
Mozz says, can see me. Thank you. Mozz
has a question.
Is it possible to set the login to
star so the user can
I've never tried.
I have never
tried,
but we can try it. So let's
just do it. Right?
Does Teleport keep logs what users do within
their sessions? Oh yeah.
Everything
is logged.
Let's see. So let's click connect.
I don't know why my one password thing
keeps showing up there.
Type who am I?
It says root, close the session.
We'll come over to activity
from there. If we had an active session,
we could actually join it.
We have session recordings, which will actually allow
me to see my typing. And what I
love, that is my favorite feature in the
whole world,
that you could scroll back.
So you can watch the entire session, see
every command, every piece of output, you know
exactly what they did.
It's just an amazing feature.
And we also have the audit log, so
you'll see all the sessions that were opened,
when I logged in again, certificate session, users
created, everything is available here too.
Can pop in here. There's some cool things
you can do that we're gonna try and
do on Mondays.
So the last workshop is where we talk
about how to move Teleport into production,
And we'll be looking at turning on some
of the more sophisticated eBPF options that give
you much better visibility into the commands that
were used.
So, yeah, we'll cover more of that then,
Jeffrey.
Cool.
So let's test
because it's slightly off script, but I
think that'll be fine,
is just to add a star to the
login tree.
Yeah, I'll just do my trait and I'm
load back in.
So, we can modify my user
and here,
I have no idea what's going to happen.
Now we modified the trait and not the
rule, so we do need to log back
in.
You
get a star.
So normally that would say Rawkode by default.
And then you would get a thing saying
unknown user,
which is why I thought I couldn't see
the server, but I did see the server
when we added me the logins. Okay. Very
cool. That's what it is.
If
your user has an empty login tree, it
doesn't show you servers.
Whereas I guess I was expected to list
the servers,
but it didn't.
Normally I would get my username.
Interesting.
All right, moving on.
So the star doesn't work.
Would have been cool. Although I'm not sure
what I would want it to do, would
it like list? Would it give me access
to every user and the password file? Like,
would I be able to connect as message
bus or at least try to? Some of
these accounts are obviously no login, but
yeah, I'm not sure why I would expect
the behavior to be there. Maybe I should
only see ones with an actual shell.
Okay.
Oh, yeah. Workshop. We're busy.
So now that we have added the logins
trait to my user,
we can
well, we did
SSH in and run whoami.
We modified the trait include root and do
that. Done. Okay. Exercise
three has where we're going to edit some
rules. We've already kind of done this and
prompt you because I was debugging why I
couldn't see the servers,
but let's do this properly this time.
So
what I'm seeing here is, well, we can
use t control users username to pull down
the YAML.
There is a helper that will allow you
to modify the rules.
And this is quite interesting.
So let's cover some of the
things that happen here. So if I do
users update
Rawkode
and I set it to editor and access,
this will remove my auditor role,
like so.
And in fact, I think what's gonna happen
here,
if I refresh this,
it's still working.
Normally it would complain at me. Let's all
go back in.
Well, maybe my, maybe my,
oh, my access rule gives me ability to
audit as well. So
let's remove that too.
Let's just give me editor.
Cool.
Now we can come in here.
I still got some stuff.
Let's log out.
Okay.
So the roles were encoded into my certificate,
I guess.
So even though I was removed, I'd have
to wait for the certificate to expire before
I lost my access.
I guess what I did during my testing,
it made me think it was gonna yell
at me. It was I actually deleted the
rules that I had access to and
it really doesn't like that. Anyway, we we
no longer see our server.
There's no applications anyway.
If we come to activity,
there's no
audit log here, there's no events.
Though I still have the ability to modify
users and roles. So I've got editor, but
I've got nothing else.
So let's just add all of that back
in.
It's just good to know that if you
don't really want to do a T control,
get users, modify the YAML, there is the
ability just to quickly update the rules from
there.
Omar is asking, am I too late? Nope.
We're gonna be here for another thirty minutes
playing with the Rawk features of Teleport.
Assuming that's what you're asking if you're late
for.
Cool.
All right. So let's try and everything we've
seen for so far has been relatively
permissive,
right? We've got star stars and a lot
of our roles, and that's not where you
wanna be when you're shipping Teleport into production.
But we actually want to restrict this access
a little bit, right?
So
what we wanna take a look at is
how do we limit access to the control
plane node by using a node label
and an edit the rule to include the
node label.
This will be really straightforward. If you wanna
go read the docs and feel free,
but we're just gonna go straight in
and play with this.
Now, the way that you add roles, labels,
the way that you add labels
to your infrastructure is in the Teleport configuration.
And we've covered this in a previous episode
two of the course, but I'll give you
the very quick TLDR,
is that if we come into the SSH
service,
you'll see here that we have a static
label. Static label means that it's hard coded
in this file.
So I can see environment
equals
staging.
You can have dynamic
labels,
which run commands. So you'll see commands here,
and then we've got the name,
and this is the name of the label,
which is going to be host name.
The command to run and any arguments that
it requires to get that value back, but
here we're just in host name. And then
just in case these values change over time
for whatever reason, unlikely with the host name,
but you never know,
how often should we run this command to
get the value for that label?
So let's add one more just because we
can, we'll call this
sessions count
and the command we're going to run will
be
who
this is even gonna work with a pipe
in it.
Maybe I'm getting too too silly here.
Period thirty
seconds.
I have no idea. Like, so who gives
you this?
Obviously, it's actually also giving me the count
one user.
Now, whenever you change the Teleport configuration, you
do need to restart it.
And now if I can't access Teleport, it
did not like that dynamic pity
label thingy.
Alright. Not too bad.
Now, don't have any surfers and that's because
we changed my rules.
I'm gonna log back in.
Executable not found.
Alright. I am gonna make that work though.
So the challenge here
is
bash
dash c
restart.
I don't know why I'm so happy with
that. But I am going to open a
new session just so I can see that
too.
Teleport.
Rawkode.
Live. Cool.
So in thirty seconds time,
I'm again, I'm hoping I'm still here. Hoping
I'm still here.
Alright. The software seems to say I'm still
online.
Twice.
We are having I think not Justin's gone.
Most
lots of The UK. I think some of
Europe's on The US. There's the storms at
the moment,
which is why I think the power
is going out. Yeah. Russell's in dark mode.
But my my five g router seems to
be handling this
more blip, which is great because it means
that I'm not having to restart the stream.
So let's go back.
So in thirty seconds, in fact, if I
refresh this now, it's been thirty seconds, we
should see session counter two.
Not important for what we're doing right now.
I just thought that was fun. So, but
we do have a environment staging label on
this machine.
And if we come back to here, then
what we want to do is to restrict
access
to this role,
to these machines.
But I'm gonna do that for
the CLI.
So we'll do a TCTL
get
roles,
roles.
Yaml.
And does that say create a role or
modify a role?
Let's create a role.
Why not?
In fact, I do rules down here, don't
I?
Okay, cool. Let's just edit a rule for
now. So we're gonna modify our access rule,
which is our catch all rule
here for anyone who wants to be able
to SSH into machine.
And instead of node labels being star star,
I could set up the session count where
two, and I'd only be able to access
the machine when I have two local sessions.
How stupid would that be? And I'm totally
gonna do it.
Two.
Alright. I know sometimes I just
do silly things, but I think it's gonna
be funny. At least I'm laughing.
So
let
me recover what I'm doing here. I will
only be able to, as someone, as a
user with access,
with the role called access,
be able to connect to a machine when
it has two active sessions.
Why?
It
should have been environment staging.
And in fact, we can add
let's
do that in a minute. Let's just do
session count first.
So let's tctl create dash f roles.
Oh, what did I break?
Not a list of the map. There we
go.
And then we'll jump over to the UI,
and we no longer have access to the
server.
Cool.
Until
I have a second session.
And this may take thirty seconds,
but that's gonna come back and I'm gonna
be so happy.
So we can and let's talk about this
rule again. I can't
if we close it, I'll never get back
on.
No.
Good question.
Russell said, can you do it as less
than two single access only? No.
You can't because
it's just not what's intended.
There's no actual it's not like an expression
that can be parsed and
evaluated.
Especially it's just after label contains session count
of a value of two. It's just not
the right match. It's not supposed to be
used in a stupid way. It's just something
that I thought would be funny.
Well, it's not work, Jay, anyway.
We'll give out an hour, ten seconds before
I
revert it to something more sensible as environment
station.
Can I create a third session? I can
100% create a third session,
but then my matcher won't work and I
won't have access to my node. Not that
I have access to it yet anyway.
Now I wonder if that's just because of
the string.
Where did I create that file?
Do Teleport,
vp 10.
Nope, my rules aren't there.
TCTL,
get rules, rules dot yaml.
BIM edit.
Let's do a sensible, my silly idea.
Yeah. It isn't working. And I wonder if
it's the string number
thing.
Access.
Oh,
did that on the server.
Okay.
Well, why did the get rules?
Did I apply it?
Am I connected to a different cluster here?
Yes.
That's my Teleport Cloud account. Okay. Stop being
silly, David.
Alright. So let's set this to an appropriate
value of env
staging.
So now anyone with the access rule can
only access
staging machines, which for us is the only
machine we have.
So let's refresh.
We have it back. Cool.
Don't know why that session can't do doesn't
work. I really thought it would.
Okay.
Okay. So now we're gonna do something really
fun.
And we're gonna talk about elevated permissions for
Teleport,
requesting access and setting up a workflow
to
really provide an environment where
you don't want to tell people they can't
go onto a machine, but you want to
make it an exception.
Like
going onto production machines, production databases using SSH
is
Oh shit, something is happening. And I should
probably make other people aware that this is
going to happen or I'm going to do
this because of the thing, right? We don't
wanna normalize
people just jumping around on machines, making changes,
right? Bad, bad, bad, bad, bad.
So what we want to do is have
a workflow for that. And what we're gonna
do here is build a workflow,
where everybody that has Teleport,
everybody that we want to have access to
Teleport
has a role called SRE.
And we all have the same access, we're
all one big team, but that access doesn't
actually allow us to get onto production machines.
So then we're going to have another role
called production,
which is going to use the Teleport feature
for requesting access,
which could be approved by any other SRE.
So we set up a dynamic where it's
like, we all can get to production, but
we have to make someone else aware that
we want access to production
and we get it. And we get it
for a certain
period of time.
And then the access will be de escalated
and
nobody can get back onto production.
Hopefully that makes sense. So we're gonna work
through it. So what we need to do
is first I need a second user.
This will be my teammate.
So we will do users
at, and I will call this user,
Mozz has been in the chat, so I'm
going to create Mozz.
Roles,
access. I'm gonna give you
everything.
Auditor.
Cool. And we will
copy this.
I'm gonna have to log out.
But that's okay.
And register.
I hate it.
When that happens, this seems to be the
port.
So we're going to get started. I'm gonna
use the same password because why not?
Like so.
And then we need to scan a second
to FA because that is not going to
get confusing.
Code two and
that is my Moz account.
Nice.
I didn't give you any login traits, which
is why you can't see in the machine,
but we're not gonna worry about that.
Okay, next on the task list. So I
have created
a new user, but we don't have our
SRE role yet, so let's create that.
So that we can just do on the
command line, so we'll call this SRE role
dot YAML.
I am not going to remember all of
this, so I'm going to click show me
the YAML,
and here is my SRE role.
Let's go through this. So we have the
name, metadata,
all Kubernetes,
we have a spec,
feels like Kubernetes,
only this time
we're going to have an allow condition
where I can request
access to production
if I get two approvals. We don't want
two, we want one because there's no I'm
not gonna create a start account, not not
for today.
Where thresholds are set to one on one.
So if one person denies it, I do
not get the access. If this was three,
I would require three people to approve it
before I got the access. But for today,
we're doing one on
Also,
this is not something I've seen in the
Teleport docs, but it'll test us and this
works. And again, I'm using this approach because
it's one team commoditizing
access and setting new norms,
not hierarchical
you cannot get onto this machine thing.
So I'm actually making it so that anyone
with the SRE role can also
approve.
Russell's saying, yes, this was the two NSE's
now need to wake up in the middle
of night for problems.
Well,
this is just the example I am using.
If you have
very limited selection of SREs following the clock,
following the sun,
then you may wish to tweak it.
However,
stick with me for the demo.
So what I'm doing different from a Teleport
documentation here is allowing this same role to
be the approver.
Because again, it's not hierarchical thing. It's not
you are not on my level, you cannot
approve this. It is, hey, we're a team.
So
we're going to save this. And in fact,
I'm just gonna in the interest of time,
I know my
segues
have meant we're a little bit behind,
as I'm gonna copy the production rule.
So what we're going to do, let's say,
okay.
The production rule allows route access to machines
marked as production.
Not just to make this work, we're gonna
go to teleport.yaml.
We can remove my session count now as
fun as that was.
We're gonna call this machine production,
restart
teleport.
The Moz user
doesn't have logins, so that won't matter.
Will it? That won't matter.
So let's come here,
Teleport.
Now what I should really do is have
one in a browser and one in a
CLI. So I could build a little request,
just kinda look at it like a silly
person.
So,
and I wanna show both floors, so we
just need to send two requests.
Cool. So I have moz here. I'm gonna
log in.
Tctl
tsh
login.
That's the clustered link. We don't want that
one today. Teleport. Rokode.io.
Password.
Is that in here yet? Rawkode test
teleport.
That's not one with two codes.
I
don't know why it's not doing a proper
sync.
One pass through a day.
Rawkode livestream.
Maybe I just got the name wrong.
Rawkode
livestream.
No, it's not a sync.
To FA code for me, not for Moz.
Yeah. I'm not applied the role yet. Oh,
good point.
I need to log in again.
Good catch, Mozz. Tctl
create Azure F
SRE rule. There we go.
Funnily enough, was testing this against an enterprise,
and I didn't know that was a constraint.
Allow request threshold is only available in enterprise
subscriptions.
Alright. But
privilege elevation is available on open source. Maybe
I just can't set the threshold.
I'm gonna have to do this against my
Teleport Cloud account.
Looks like it's still set request. Maybe I
don't know about approval.
I don't know whether to test this or
just go through my other one.
Let's see what happens.
So I'm gonna re log in
here.
These computers are just mean to me.
A
lot of times I am mean to them.
So, one second
again.
Cool.
So we're gonna do tctl
request
ls. Now this will allow me to list
all the requests. Currently, there are none. If
we do dash dash help, they will see
that we can request access to another role.
So we'll do tctl
request
create,
and then we specify
the roles that we need access to and
a reason.
So here I can say, well,
I
Rawkode
roles.
I want production.
And the reason is live
stream.
I didn't modify my user.
User.
Yeah.
Users Rawkode.
Alright. We need to get myself.
S r e rule.
T c t l create dash f Rawkode.
And I'm 100% gonna have to log in
again, but I am just gonna try.
Oh, it worked.
Okay.
I
don't care. That means I don't have to
log in again and do that password then.
Now we can do request ls.
What we can see here is Rawkode has
requested the permission
role production
and the reason why is that it's a
live stream.
Yeah.
Teleport knows blah blah blah blah blah. Very
funny.
Okay. So let's go back to our Moz
user
and
Moz doesn't have anything.
Normally, I would see requests.
SRE,
refresh.
So I'm starting to think that
this isn't avail the UI component isn't available
there.
So I am gonna have to
pctl
tsh login
again
and juggle some accounts. Okay, Moz, your turn.
I'll show you the enterprise UI as well,
just so you can see where the differ.
I wasn't aware of this.
Second code.
Oh, m
user moz.
Log in.
Second code.
Okay.
Alright. So it's logged me out of my
other user, but that's okay.
So we should now be able to do
TCTL request ls. We'll see Rawkode require.
That is the because Rawkode logged out.
Is it because Rawkode logged out?
You You know, I'm just going to use
my enterprise one to show this.
Yeah. It's correct. Okay.
Because I can't have two people logged in
and through the CLI, so I can't show
you the CLI flow.
I'm just gonna have to use my other
one.
Okay. So I do have a Teleport cloud
account and
I can log in with me.
And for some reason, one password just seems
to mess this bit up every single time.
Okay.
I'll make that bigger.
And now
we have access requests and you'll see I
was playing with this earlier.
I don't know why that
okay. Doesn't matter. We have access requests here
and you'll see that we can view it.
And I said help me five hours ago.
And
my SRE user said, sure thing and approved
it.
So let's do that again then.
So let me update my
current profile
to be
Rawkode
Teleport. S h.
Bless requests.
There's my approved one,
and let's just remove it.
Okay.
I thought okay. We'll make a new one.
Quests,
create.
Okay. It's still there. Rally stream two.
Oh, my username here is david@rokode.com.
And I'm hoping it doesn't say you already
have.
Probably because I already have access to production.
Oh, well.
So once it's approved,
you can assume the rule.
What?
I've broken everything.
There isn't a production rule.
So this is the thing I was talking
about earlier when I deleted the rule and
it complained at me because I still had
their role.
I am having the best time. Alright.
We have the roles here. Let's do this
one more time and walk through.
And I don't mind that I'm gonna go
a bit over because this is fun.
I was having
a great time with this feature.
Okay. Rules
dot YAML,
apply TCTL
create dash f.
Oh, wrong one. Rules.
Hopefully that doesn't have the server.
Alright. SRE and production were created.
We can refresh
and there we go.
Alright.
So now I'm gonna create that new request
again.
Production.
Hopefully that works.
It doesn't tell me I already have.
Yeah.
I wonder if the RM would work now
with that. Maybe that was just because the
rule didn't exist.
I just don't have permission.
Okay.
Delete on access request.
Well, I am an editor.
Whatever.
Oh, we do have the moz user. Moz
hasn't requested that. Okay, let's do that.
So I'm gonna
We have the SRE user. Let's close it
or not. Not much.
SRE.
Got to get me on. My
one password says password you're telling me is
wrong.
Computers are tough. TCTL
users add moz
roles,
auditor access,
editor,
login,
go.
I should have given you.
Should have given users.
Users, Mozz. Let's see if I can modify
you before I've created you.
Awesome. Roles,
so I don't have to log in 14,000
times.
SRE.
Awesome.
Create
dash f moz.
Okay. Now we're gonna register your account moz.
Just open it in my browser. Okay. Cool.
And I am going to use the s
r e user's password.
And
scanny scanny scanny.
That's gonna be the second code because I
I I just like making this much more
difficult for myself.
Great.
Thank you. Okay.
So
now I am going to request access. So
this is the Moz user who is in
the SRE role, who can request access to
production
and say live stream
would really
like working
and demo,
please.
Thanks.
Can't leave the table in there. Okay.
Send request.
Awesome.
So now we can see this.
Now me
can do requests
l s
Approve
request ID.
Computer.
I did all of this this morning.
Prove
request ID.
What have I done to my user account?
I
am
confused.
Is that not Miles's request?
Oh, you're right.
Where is Maltese request?
If I had broken my user.
Yeah. Jeffrey's on there too. Yeah. I am
approving the wrong quest.
User Rawkode.
I don't have the the SRE role.
Okay. So we're gonna get my user.
I don't have the SRE rule. Why? I
did it.
That's because I've been jumping between clusters.
Alright.
Let's do that.
And I'm probably gonna have to re authenticate,
but
desperation,
I'm going to list request.
Awesome. I didn't. Now I can approve
Just want it to work. It worked earlier.
I am
I'm going to give myself the ability to
do everything on this machine and tell Teleport
to to just stop it.
It's late. I'm tired.
Editor. Edit. Alright.
Rules.
Resources.
Access request.
Verbs.
That's the list right? Yep. List,
create,
read,
delete,
update.
Anything else? No. Save.
Not a valid resource declaration. And why are
you yelling at me? I can't do it.
Star star.
You know, it let me list it, but
I did think I was gonna have to
log out.
So
for the last time,
that's the wrong cluster now because we switched.
I'm going to log in and just make
sure I have the right rules that I
need to do this job.
Thank you all for your extreme patience as
I confuse the fucker of myself.
Request
alias.
Gonna list it on my rules this time.
Prove.
Yeah. I just have to laugh, don't I?
I didn't change my SRE rule today.
Yeah. So I can request production threshold, but
we want one.
I think it's because I have that function
already.
I think that's the problem.
I think it's doing some checks and then
oh, no. Wait.
That's wrong.
Oh, no. That's right. I can review the
quests for the production role.
And if I go to production
yeah. Perfect.
I
mean, I can't confirm
because I can't
delete my old my rule assumption.
My only option right now is to create
a third user.
Russell
rules,
auditor,
access,
editor,
logins,
route,
h one Russell, says the day.
You know the only impartial user in this
current Teleport code set up.
And I
yeah. Open.
Okay.
I'm not adding a third.
Russell.
Scan, scan, scan.
Alright. So let's try this. Right? And then
I'll I'll I'll talk about why I think
this is what's happening.
Rawkode can't see shit.
I then give him SRE rule. Oh, David.
What are you doing?
Cool.
Okay.
Now,
I can do this to the UI or
I can log myself out of the CLI
and do it from there. You give ten
seconds, say CLI or UI and I'll go,
I'll do it. But we have now what
appears to be a working approval process. And
then I will explain my hypothesis about why
I got in such a convoluted situation in
the first place.
Oh, ten seconds.
Do you wanna see the UI flow or
the CLI flow?
Maybe you just don't care.
CLI from Russell.
Okay.
So I am going to log out of
Russell on the UI.
We are going to become
Moz.
Jeffrey wants a CLI too. Good. Right.
Same. Good. So this is going to log
me in.
Hopefully as Moz,
who sent the approval process. He is waiting
for his access to this server.
Now,
on the CLI,
I am gonna have to TSH login
this time
as Russell
on the server.
Russell, Russell, Russell.
Cool.
And now Russell should be able to see
that Mars put in a request
for production access.
Request
ls.
Approve.
I'm pretty sure you can add a reason.
Go for it.
I bet you it's broken on the CLI.
Is that what the problem is?
So it's not me being stupid.
Right?
My my weird hypothesis that I was making
up in my head to explain what the
fuck was going on. Oh, I really need
to change that recovery
code now.
No. So my hypothesis is kinda right. Like,
I can't approve Moz
because Moz approved me.
So
now I'm going to log in as Mars.
Wait, Mars opened the request.
Russell.
Just keep saying the name.
And Russell can approve Mozzie's request.
Prove.
These are all being so patient. Jeffrey, let's
see the UI. Russell, yeah, sure. Let's see
the UI. Awesome.
I have I have no idea anymore.
Approved.
No, it didn't.
It did approve it.
That request was created
while the threshold was still set to two.
I'm a media.
Who am I on the CLI?
Who who I'm Russell.
And I bet you the CLI is not
gonna let me delete the request because the
CLI apparently cannot deal with request.
RM.
Yeah. Fuck it.
I'm so upset.
And it didn't work in that. Okay. That's
right.
Okay.
The CLI
does not work for approval processes. That is
100%
broken.
Unfortunately, the module request was created
while
the threshold was set to two.
So we're gonna adjust very quickly
because sure I'm gonna be able to get
it to work quickly.
I sent this to one, isn't actually gonna
fix it because at least for the existing
request, because if I come back in, there's
definitely one. Yep. It goes to access request,
it's still gonna be stuck
there. However,
what we can do
is have Russell submit a request
from the CLI.
And I'm Russell here. Right?
Okay.
Request
create
Russell
rules
production
reason,
please,
please, please.
So you can create them.
Let me start something.
And now
I am Russell.
Let's see if David's gonna prove it. Fuck
it. Why not?
No.
Assuming because I've already assumed the role.
Moz hasn't had his request approved yet.
This is more complicated
than some very complicated films I'm thinking of.
Hey, come on, Moz. It's your turn to
save the day.
Prove.
Approve.
Wow.
Russell now has axe
to sumer rule.
Yes.
Okay. Which means
I can do TSH
login
proxy
request
ID.
I need the request ID first.
Well, in fact it was
here.
PSH login
request ID. This is how I assume the
role as Russell.
Update my certificate.
PSHLF.
It's just because
fuck it. I don't know.
Did I restart it after setting the node
to be production?
Who knows anymore?
So Russell should have the production role right
now.
In fact, I do have the production role
right now.
But it would appear I can't list the
machines
because I have no idea what day of
the week is anymore.
ENV
production.
Same. Right?
When
I created Russell, did I give him logins?
Who knows? I I'm I think I'm giving
up. I'm I'm just gonna record a video
on this later because I have no idea
what day of the week is anymore.
And you can't modify traits from the UI.
Users.
Russell.
At least we're learning Teleport stuff. Right? Log
in through. Yeah.
Yes, it's status.
I am Russell web production role enabled.
Why the hell can I not see the
note?
Why can I not see the node?
I'm not faint anymore.
There is a forty minute version of
role escalation and teleport,
which worked first time on my testing this
afternoon, and I feel like everything that could
go wrong
did go wrong.
Russell may be right.
Actual Russell, not my fakers or Russell. And
that maybe the CLI just can't see the
notes.
So
I'm more than happy to test that.
Russell.
Why is that server not showing up?
Doesn't matter.
Alright.
Well, this is a really cool feature. I
don't know what crazy magic I have done
to be able to break that, but
the last task that we were gonna be
taking a look at is to enforce MFA.
So
this is another really cool feature and I
do want this to work and to show
you it. So let's
log in
as
me, actual real
me, my account.
Okay.
If I can't assume and see my server,
this didn't me assume the role. I've got
five hours left, but the server just isn't
showing up.
So to be honest, all I'm going to
do is,
I'm just gonna do it through the UI,
just so it's quick, is modify the access.
We'll table star star.
My trade login.
Teleport.
Just remove the labels.
See when it clicks.
Course this isn't working. I haven't added that
node to the cloud account.
How did nobody notice that?
Funny. Alright.
Funny. So so funny.
I'm not gonna add the label back.
I will fix this
and then we're gonna do something cool.
Teleport cloud password.
Because my node that I'm using and modifying
the config on is the node, which is
connected to the teleport I spun up on
a scale AVM and not my teleport cloud
instance.
Now I need to log in as me
on the CLI, I have to generate a
token for node access and register this node
with the cluster.
So we can use the
TSH tokens command.
Oh, yeah. Talking.
We had a role.
What's a role
type
node TTL.
You know what? I just I don't even
need I don't even need an ever. Just
giving the damn thing.
One each.
And then we'll grab this
and then here, I'm just going to stop
Teleport, go away.
Now it's gonna be registered as a node
on my Teleport Cloud account. And now I'll
be able to do TSHLS.
If I assume my thing again.
Not connected yet.
Oh, come on.
Off server is
Rawkode
Teleport SH 3025.
Why is that not working?
Well, the IP address is different for a
star.
I am Mimi. Right? Yeah. I'm Mimi.
I created a token.
My cloud account.
Awesome.
Alright. Let's just modify Teleport. Yaml.
That's gonna be a bit awkward.
Roles mode. That's my token.
You know, I'll even take this pen off.
I don't care. Just work.
Rawkode.
Teleport. Oh, yeah. Four four three.
I'm using the single proxy mode, which means
I probably obviously have to pay.
Why is it not working there?
Okay. I just did that.
I'm doing that too.
Teleport start rules. No. There's my token. Okay.
Four four three is what the UI says
I should do.
And then it complained.
No. Firewall's
not nice.
Nice gas.
What to be certain to me?
Can I just run it on my own
machine?
Cat e dot s h.
I just want a machine.
Alright.
I don't care about this and real stuff
anymore.
Teleport
here.
Livestream account.
There's more labels.
Could we delete them for a test?
Probably.
I don't remember anything anymore.
Why can I not see that machine?
Oh, there's a load labels here.
Wise man would have just left. Okay.
So now if I try and connect to
this machine
Azure,
it'll work.
What we want to enable
is MFA.
So
we can add
this
to a role.
This will require any session MFA to be
enabled when we try and connect to a
machine. I wanted to do this on the
production one to show a viable use case,
but we are ninety minutes into this and
I need something to work.
So I'm just going to modify the role
for the UI.
I'm gonna just say access
spec
require
MFA.
I don't know if I have to log
out and log back in.
I have no idea.
No.
Cool. Well, yep.
This doesn't work.
I may not even say bye. I may
just turn off my computer.
Did I enable you?
Did I?
It got merged.
Okay.
Yeah. That was silly. If I view this
again, now it should be there.
Yeah. Okay. Cool.
I'll take that one. That was that was
all me.
So finally.
Alright.
So now
from here,
we go t s h l s.
What account is that?
Teleport Rawkode.
Live.
Really?
Really, really, really, really. Okay. The mod is
on that cluster.
Rawkode.
Okay. And then I need this password again.
I need this TFA again.
And now,
Teleport.
They tell me that we need OTP,
which I can copy
from here.
Now that's complaining because I see I I
tried to log in twice or use the
same one time password within a thirty second
period.
So let's copy that.
And we're in. So Teleport.
Wow.
There's a really cool feature, which is available
in open source. You can use request elevation
in open source. I think some of it
is hidden from the UI. I'm gonna speak
to the team and work out exactly what
went wrong tonight cause I'm not entirely sure.
But you can elevate your permissions, you can
assume the role, access the infrastructure, really awesome
feature. And then there's the final piece of
our back end stuff is we can enable
that a one time password is required at
the session level. Now from a CLI, that's
my OTP,
from the web, it would be a hardware
token.
And there are plenty of ways to add
the hardware token to your account.
TSH MFA,
where you can add stuff from here. So
I am not even gonna attempt to do
anything else. There isn't anything else that was
everything in the tutorial,
but that was quite a slog. So thank
you for your patience.
I'm gonna pop back over here.
So Russell says that is a nice feature
only allowing an MFA code once. Yep. I
had no idea
until you had it and then you realize
and it's annoying.
But I hope that was useful. I know
that we spend a lot of time in
this session
debugging and fighting with the roles and juggling
users and juggling clusters and I got myself
a little bit in a fluster,
but you know, do go wrong.
I like to show things when they go
wrong And I hope that the process of
pulling out roles, editing roles, playing with users
was viable or useful to some of you.
So again, thank you for staying with me.
I hope it was I hope you enjoyed
this. What I would say now is enjoy
your weekend. Russell is telling me to go
get a drink and have a good one.
I'm gonna go have a few drinks now
for sure. I'll be going home and cracking
off a cold one pretty soon.
But we'll be back on Monday. I'm gonna
be talking about moving Teleport into production.
So join us then. Have a wonderful weekend,
and I'll see you all soon.
Thanks.